but first they blew off his door
then specialist firearms officers piled
into the suspect's home
the met officers used dozens of stun
grenades
their target is suspected of gun crimes
and major drug trafficking
he's one of hundreds of alleged top
criminals arrested in raids across the
country
this is an amazing moment i think for uk
policing and uk
law enforcement thanks to our partners
in the national crime agency and
internationally we have been able
to hit the most senior levels of
organized crime
where it hurts most getting people
arrested
seizing their cash stopping their
distribution networks in a way that
i have literally never seen before this
is what two million pounds looks like
seized in one raid by scotland yard
detectives
in another they found five million
pounds the most ever
from one suspect all british police
forces were involved in operation
phonetic
so far they've arrested 746 suspects
they've seized more than 54 million
pounds in cash
2 tons of cocaine 77 firearms including
automatic weapons
and 55 luxury cars these are people who
are causing
vast amounts of misery and harm across
the uk
these are what we would call iconic
untouchables people
who for many many years have worked with
impunity
and evaded law enforcement and now we've
been able to get inside and see exactly
what they're doing
this encrypted phone system was the key
to the police success
top villains thought it was impregnable
but detectives infiltrated it
there's a panic pin which you can put in
which is the level behind this
and if that is put on the device it will
wipe any information stored on the
device
but when you're sending messages you can
also select something called burn time
which will give a set amount of time
from when you've sent the message
to when it will be deleted from the
recipients or from the recipients and
from the sender's device
dozens of suspects have been charged and
are awaiting trial
two law enforcement officers were among
those arrested
the investigation is expected to last
many months
or longer martin brunt sky news